[Applaudissements]
on me dit souvent qu internet est un
lieu bouillonnant d'innovation moi je
suis de plus en plus gênés par cette
idée
j'ai l'impression qu'internet est de
plus en plus bloquée en quelque sorte
que la machine s'est enrayée quelque
part depuis combien de temps on n'a pas
vu émerger un nouveau grands acteurs du
numérique capable de mettre en danger
les grands leaders technologiques
actuels dans la décennie 2000 on a vu
apparaître facebook et twitter à la fin
de la décennie sont nés au beurre la
blaquart
airbnb mais depuis 2010 rien de
bouleversant et là on arrive à la fin la
décennie et on va toujours rien
apparaître
pourquoi parce que la technologie n'a
jamais était aussi concentré et parce
que surtout il ya une concentration des
capacités d'innovation dans les mains de
quelques entreprises un chiffre parmi
d'autres aujourd'hui google et facebook
accapare 99 % de la croissance de la
publicité en ligne
99% le problème c'est que cette
concentration
elle risque encore de s'aggraver avec le
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle où il ya l'ia est d'autant
plus forte qu'elle est nourri de données
or en matière de données
les géants du numérique sont les rois
alors posons nous la question
technologiquement la victoire des géants
du numérique qu'ils soient américains ou
asiatiques
d'ailleurs marc telle la fin de
l'histoire autrement dit la france et
l'europe ont elles ont perdu la bataille
en matière d'internet
moi je pense que
effectivement c'est possible qu'on ait
perdu cette bataille mais des batailles
il y en aura d'autres et il y en a
justement une nouvelle se profile à
l'horizon
cette bataille elle est portée par une
technologie qui promet d'en finir avec
la centralisation du web
cette technologie c'est celle qui a
permis l'émergence des crypto monnaie
comme le bitcoin elle s'appelle la
bloque chain la bloque chain ça permet
de résoudre un obstacle
une chose qui n'était pas possible
jusqu'à présent échanger sur internet de
la valeur de pair à pair
c'est à dire d'un individu à un autre
sans passer par une autorité centrale
je prends un exemple aujourd'hui si je
vais envoyer un fichier une chanson un
document word à un ami sur internet en
fait je n'en vois pas ce cliché je vais
envoyer une copie
ce fichier et moi je garde l'original
sur mon ordinateur
le problème c'est que ça c'est pas
viable pour ce qui est fondée sur de
leur rareté
si j'envoie un euro un ami et que je
conserve cet euro l'euro et perd de sa
valeur
donc internet tel qu'il est conçu
empêche de pouvoir envoyer de la valeur
de pair à pair sans passer par une
autorité centrale
c'est ce problème fondamental que résout
la bloque chain et l'exemple
d'application le plus connu ces échanges
de bitcoin d'une personne à à une
personne b sans passer par un quelconque
tiers et sans même avoir besoin un
compte bancaire ce qu'il faut rappeler
que deux milliards de personnes sur
cette planète n'ont pas de compte
bancaire au coeur de cette technologie
il ya une notion essentielle c'est la
décentralisation alors la
décentralisation c'est une notion qui
bouscule nous a priori une certitude
peut se demander
comment est ce qu'un système central un
système peut fonctionner sans autorité
centrale justement par exemple comment
un système monétaire peut fonctionner
sans banques donc la décentralisation
c'est un changement de paradigme
radicale mais en fait c'est extrêmement
naturelle quand on étudie les grands
systèmes complexes du monde
le cerveau la forêt etc
on s'aperçoit que la plupart de ces
systèmes sont fondés sur une
intelligence ou une autorité qui est
décentralisée et internet
à l'origine était fondée sur ce principe
donc la décentralisation de la bio
tchane va permettre de revenir à
l'esprit originel d'internet et surtout
elle va ouvrir des perspectives
considérables
ce qui se joue c'est rien de moins qu'un
nouveau web dans ce web décentraliser
les règles de l'économie numérique
classique qui ont fondé sur la
centralisation sont bousculés prenons un
exemple aujourd'hui pour se financer
une start-up doit convaincre des fonds
de capital risque qui vont financer son
développement dans le web décentraliser
une start-up pourra faire appel à une
multitude d'internautes qui viendront
injecté non pas de l'euro ou du dollar
mais de la crypto monnaie pour les start
up
ça va permettre un accès aux
financements bien plus égalitaire une
start up en afrique pour relever autant
millions une start up dans la silicon
valley et les internautes eux qu'est-ce
qu'ils y viennent y gagne non pas comme
aujourd'hui des parts de l'entreprise
est ce qu'on appelle un token un jetons
en français alors c'est quoi
tokyo un token c'est un actif numérique
qu'on peut transférer et non pas copier
un autre individu sur internet
instantanément sans passer par une
autorité centrale le bitcoin est le
premier document qui a été créée en 2009
un grand h
des token c'est qu'ils sont échangeables
en temps réel avec n'importe qui sur des
plateformes mais surtout le token ça va
permettre une chose à son détenteur
pouvoir utiliser le service qui sera
développée par la start up
je prends un exemple en ce moment
pendant que je vous parle je n'utilise
pas mon smartphone ou d'un ordinateur et
ce smartphone
cet ordinateur ils ont on appelle de la
puissance de calcul c'est à dire que
cette puissance elle permet de faire
tourner des applications
et bien en fait il ya un projet qui
s'appelle golem qui va permettre de
vendre la puissance de calcul de nous
apparaît électronique pendant qu'on ne
les utilise pas en échange on va
recevoir ce qu'on appelle des toqués
golem al'inverse contre des topiaires
golem on va pouvoir acheter de la
puissance de calcul à moindre coût ce
qui pourra être par exemple extrêmement
pratique pour la recherche médicale ou
plein d'autres applications golem
c'est un exemple parmi des centaines
d'autres avec les token on peut
envisager des choses considérable par
exemple on peut envisager le fait que
les token change de la notion même de
start up
aujourd'hui il s'agit de avec les
startups de concentrer la valeur au sein
d'une entité décentralisée avec le token
il s'agira de partager cette valeur au
sein d'une organisation décentralisée
entre des détenteurs des taux kent se
partager de ce bras de façon bien plus
équitable et aussi de façon bien plus
intelligente parce que chacun aura
intérêt économiquement à faire grandir
le projet pourquoi parce que faire
grandir le projet ça voudrait dire faire
grandir la valeur du token on pourra
échanger instantanément avec n'importe
qui sur des plateformes
autre avantage puisque l' organisation
est décentralisée
son créateur n'en n'est plus le maître
absolu contrairement au géant du web
ils ne contrôlent le contrôlera plus les
données de ses utilisateurs
on n'aura plus un facebook qui pourra
changer ses fonctionnalités ou ses
conditions générales du jour au
lendemain alors en fait la
décentralisation permise par la doctrine
c'est un atout énorme où chacun peut
s'emparer internet
ça a permis de décentraliser
l'information avec internet
n'importe qui peut publier et échanger
l'information qu'il veut auprès du monde
entier instantanément sans demander la
permission à quiconque les token et la
bloque shine ça va permettre de
décentraliser la valeur n'importe qui
pourra créer et échanger de la valeur
avec n'importe qui instantanément sans
demander la permission à personne alors
peut-être que vous vous dites
cette histoire de token c'est un peu du
charabia
si je vous en parle aujourd'hui c'est
parce que des milliers de gens avance en
ce moment sur ces questions et nous ne
nous attendent pas nous en france il ya
un bouillonnement partout dans le monde
un bouillonnement intellectuel
technologique qui est absolument
fascinant sur ces sujets et c'est pour
ça que j'ai décidé de créer moi-même mon
entreprise il ya quelques années dans ce
secteur en 1995 seulement 30 millions de
personnes utilisaient internet la
plupart des investisseurs étaient très
sceptiques
aujourd'hui quand je parle de blocs
shine et de crypto monnaie je tombe
aussi sur pas mal de scepticisme
d'abord on me dit que c'est très
compliqué d'utilisation et c'est vrai
mais internet aussi c'était très dur à
utiliser dans les années 90 c'était un
truc de geek
les interfaces elle était très laide à
l'étape et e-bay en 98 vous allez avoir
fait l'expérience
c'est assez stupéfiant en fait dans les
années 2000 les entrepreneurs ils ont
compris que ce qui comptait c'était
l'expérience utilisateur et à partir de
ils ont travaillé ça internet a commencé
à se développer donc cet argument la
difficulté d'utilisation
c'est un argument qui uniquement
provisoire ensuite on dit oui mais les
crypto monnaie c'est une gigantesque
bulle internet aussi a connu sa bulle ça
n'a pas empêché se développer parce
qu'il y avait une vraie technologie
prometteuse
derrière c'est pareil avec la bonne
chère alors vous dit peut-être ok très
bien mais si on peut éviter la bulle
c'est peut-être mieux en fait pas
forcément il ya une économiste qui
s'appelle carlotta perez qui a étudié
toutes les innovations technologiques
depuis l'ère industrielle
ces conclusions elles sont très claires
très souvent les bulles c'est le moteur
de l'adoption des technologies
pourquoi parce qu'en fait le capital
financier il va servir à financer les
différentes infractions techniques qui
coûte très cher donc les bulles ça une
utilité c'est même essentiel dans le
développement des innovations
technologiques alors à ce stade vous dit
peut-être ok très bien elle problème
fondamental c'est que les crypto monnaie
ça sert à rien on parle d'un truc qui
est sensé et changer le monde
on peut même pas payer son café avec et
c'est vrai on peut pas payer son café
mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est que c'est
peut-être pas fait pour ça aujourd'hui
le cacher le la carte bancaire ça marche
déjà très bien en fait les crypto
monnaie ça va surtout créer des nouveaux
usages
ces exemples de gaulle n dont je parlais
tout à l'heure il y en aura des
centaines d'autres dont les années 90
les gens voyaient pas très bien allez
quoi à quoi allait servir internet
concrètement et honnêtement en 95
qui aurait parié sur l'émergence
quinze ans plus tard de humber de airbnb
de blabla coeur etc
pas grand monde c'est la même chose avec
la bloquer tout est à inventer
c'est ça qui est fascinant et
passionnant
ma conviction c'est qu'on ne battra pas
les géants du numérique sur leur propre
terrain il faut investir le terrain de
demain mais ce qu'il nous faut surtout
pas faire c'est répéter l'erreur
monumentale du minitel internet aurait
dû être français c'est un chercheur
français louis pouzin vient vanter les
prémices du protocole tcp ip était à
l'origine internet mais le gouvernement
français persuadés que l'avenir était
dans le minitel et non pas dans
l'internet a décidé de couper les
subventions de l'ue faisant résultats
ces travaux ont été repris par deux
chercheurs américains qui ont ensuite
développé ce qui est devenu internet
cette arrogance là elle nous a coûté
très cher et on en paye encore
aujourd'hui le prix alors ne ratons pas
la nouvelle bataille n'est pas condamné
avoir toujours un train de retard en
russie poutine a rencontré le fondateur
d'une des blocs chaînes les plus
importantes et therion il a compris
qu'il y avait un intérêt stratégique
dans cette technologie et nous en france
nous en se targue de vouloir être leader
dans l'innovation de rupture c'est pas
qu'il dise notre miss de l'économie et
qu'est ce que ça veut dire vouloir être
leader dans l'innovation de rupture
pour moi ça voudrait dire ça devrait
impliquer deux choses la première c'est
comprendre que la méthode compte au
moins autant que l'argent qu'on y met
c'est pas simplement mettre 10 milliards
d'euros 11 un fonds pour l'innovation de
rupture qui compte c'est par où on les
met dans le cas de la bonne chère qu'il
faut savoir c'est que l'innovation ne se
crée pas dans les universités elles ne
se crée pas dans les labos de recherche
ne s'est créé pas non plus dans les
grandes entreprises
elle se crée dans les communautés de
développeurs et c'est très différent
la deuxième chose à comprendre c'est que
devenir leader dans une innovation de
rupture
sa demande de faire des paris est donc
de prendre des risques
on parle beaucoup de intelligence
artificielle
aujourd'hui mais c'est plus un pari
l'intelligence artificielle
on sait
ça doit être ça va devenir une grande
technologies du futur c'était avant
quand c'était pas encore quand c'est
encore un pari qu'il fallait mettre les
moyens le plus conséquent
aujourd'hui c'est très tard pour devenir
leader le problème c'est que en france
on a souvent un peu de rab de retard à
l'allumage sur l'innovation
par exemple on a mis beaucoup de temps à
croire en l'informatique au début on
entendait dire que c'était une mode et
que ça allait passer
en 85 à polytechnique la question était
encore de savoir s'il fallait enseigner
l'informatique
ensuite une fois que c'est devenu plus
évident que l'informatique allait être
incontournable est arrivé
cette chose qu'on appelle internet on
savait pas trop si c'était sérieux ou
pas ce truc là donc le gouvernement de
l'époque a commandé un rapport pour se
faire une idée
conclusion du rapport remis en 94
internet 1 n'est pas adapté aux fournir
des services commerciaux 2 ne deviendra
sûrement pas le réseau numérique de
référence au même moment
jeff bezos lancé amazon heureusement il
ya quand même deux bonnes nouvelles la
première c'est qu'on a tous les talents
en france pour réussir
on a des ingénieurs de grande qualité on
a des cryptographe et des mathématiciens
qui sont reconnus mondialement
on a des excellents talent créatif vous
savez que l'iphone a été inventé par un
français jean marie hullot a été
débauché de l'inria par steve jobs et
qui a travaillé en secret pendant quatre
ans à paris sur l'iphone donc les
talents les à la deuxième bonne nouvelle
c'est que les géants du numérique n'ont
pas leur place dans le monde l'autre
chaîne
pourquoi parce que tout leur business
model repose sur la centralisation
donc c'est à l'opposé c'est pour ça que
ma conviction c'est que ces deux
nouveaux acteurs qui vont émerger avec
de nouvelles règles de nouvelles
stratégies et de nouveaux métiers aussi
comment émerger économistes du token
juriste spécialisé en cryptant manet etc
tout est inventé
et c'est justement maintenant qu'il faut
faire les efforts qu'il faut
donc il est encore temps on les a pas
fait sur l'intelligence artificielle
quand il fallait et on voit maintenant à
quel point c'est dur de rattraper notre
retard
alors ce nouveau web il est encore
naissant et donc forcément bancal mais
c'est justement pendant ces périodes
d'ébullition que c'est la chose la plus
intéressante qu'elle se construise c'est
la période la plus passionnante
d'abord parce que c'est durant ces
premiers temps que les choses les plus
essentiels de ce fonds souvenons nous
que amazon a été écrit des 94 google des
98 mais c'est une période passionnante
aussi et surtout parce que chacun peut
encore prendre en marche le train de la
bonne chaîne qui vient tout juste de
s'élancer
merci
[Applaudissements]